[Music]
so
do
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
this
hey good evening and welcome to the
table my name is karen
miner i'm part of the leadership team
and i just want to welcome you tonight
and kick off
our service on this cold and drizzly
evening baby it's cold outside i've got
my
hot tea to keep my hands warm and i hope
that this time together warms you
in some way remind you you're not alone
that even though we're not meeting
together
we are still a community that loves and
cares for one another
and so whether you've been with us for a
long time
or you're just joining us for the first
time that includes everyone
so welcome welcome uh if you
are watching on facebook or i think
youtube does comments too right
take a moment and uh let us know that
you're watching
put your name let us know where you're
watching from we would
love the opportunity to connect with you
directly and personally i just have one
announcement
tonight and that is about christmas eve
we are planning on doing an outdoor
socially distanced bring your own chairs
wear your masks stay away from people as
much as you can
so that we can celebrate christmas eve
together at pleasant valley church
outdoors but you know with everything
right now we are holding those plans
loosely
and we are continuing to look at the
numbers
monitor those we're also wanting to
really align with our value
for um just being communal and
thoughtful
and wanting to keep everyone safe and
healthy throughout the holiday season
and beyond
not just our our own church community
but those that we come in contact with
other days aside from church so
um you know we all know how to be
flexible by now
that's kind of the the name of the game
in 2020
with kovids so just keep keep
uh checking back with us on sundays and
uh hopefully you're on brett's email
distribution list
he will be sending out more information
as we get closer
but hopefully we'll be able to do
something christmas eve if not we will
be right here
online as always
so hope you'll join us either way
as we transition into worship tonight i
wanted to share
a verse with you and it's one that i've
been
thinking about quite a bit this week um
just with life you know i don't have to
say too much beyond that
life right now can be hard so
this is a passage from matthew chapter
and i'm going to read it out of the
message paraphrase which is basically
just
plain english but also really poetic and
beautiful
and it's jesus speaking to a crowd and
he's just actually gone off on them
like he got very frustrated with them
for
uh you know doing their own thing and
he's tried to invest so much into these
people but they're not
not paying attention they're just kind
of going their own way and
he takes a moment to pray and
centers himself and then he's able to
respond with compassion
and you know i feel like that's a word
right now
that i need that i think we all need
just to remember when life gets hectic
and chaotic
and messy uh two
just pause take a moment
very simple like god help me right now
that kind of a prayer
so this is what jesus says are you tired
worn out burned out on religion
come to me get away with me and you'll
recover
your life i'll show you how to take a
real rest
walk with me and work with me watch how
i do it
learn the unforced rhythms of grace
i won't lay anything heavy or
ill-fitting on you
keep company with me and you'll learn to
live freely
and lightly let's pray
god help us to return to you tonight
and to remember there is no shame in
returning
in fact you rejoice when we return to
you
even if it's just a quick prayer a quick
centering moment
desperate help me jesus moment
but god we return to you and we center
on you tonight
help us to remember that you are with us
and when we center on you when we walk
with you
when we are in your presence you teach
us
how to live freely
and lightly and to have peace
no matter the circumstance that's our
prayer tonight god
and we thank you for your love and your
faithfulness
in jesus name amen
[Music]
hey guys thanks for joining us again
tonight we're glad y'all are here with
us
and um if we haven't met you
guys before i'm mindy and these are my
sisters
actually i'm really grateful for all the
opportunities that we get to do music
together it's one of the joys
of our life so i hope it's a blessing to
you guys as well
um one of the things that we were
talking about
um just even um
in our family right now there's a lot
that's been going on that's just been
heavy
and and some painful things um
watching people we love walk through
really difficult situations
and then even just the small like uh
practical
you know nuisances of life like your
heat are breaking in the middle of
winter
um you know and both the heavy things
and the light things
um what i hope that we are doing
as as a community as people who are
saying we want to follow the way of
jesus
is being able to name and acknowledge
the pain that's in our lives
and yet still hold intention the faith
that draws us back to a god who is able
to
teach us in those moments to comfort us
in those moments to make us more like
him
um and
and really uh learn how
how to sit in the middle of pain and
also
uh trust a loving god um who is for us
and who is for you and whatever you're
going through um
so i just invite you into that space
with us tonight um
yeah where you can hold intention both
both the pain and the beauty
that is around you um wherever you find
yourself
so uh yeah y'all just join in as we sing
and
[Music]
and um the ones who feel like they
are done this
is a word to all the ones who feel
[Music]
forgotten
alive and we're shaking we're alive
alive
the light alive
[Music]
your mercy is rising like the sun on the
horizon
coming home
[Music]
alive
foreign
[Music]
lord if you can use us fill us up
is
[Music]
fill us up
[Applause]
[Music]
i
alive
[Music]
be the mountain where
is
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
you're never gonna
you're never
[Music]
you're never gonna
let me
[Music]
never gonna let me down
you're never gonna let me down
[Music]
is
oh on
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
in christ
the lord
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
is
wrapped in our flesh
right into the midst of our chaos
you experienced life
in all its beauty and all its mess
[Music]
and you continue to transform us
we worship you we adore you
we find you here present with us
thank you god for being
with us
matthew 1 18-25
the birth of jesus took place like this
his mother mary was engaged to be
married to joseph
before they came to the marriage bed
joseph discovered she was pregnant
it was by the holy spirit but he didn't
know that
joseph shargrin but noble determined to
take care of things quietly so mary
would not be disgraced
while he was trying to figure a way out
he had a dream
god's angel spoke in the dream joseph
son of david
don't hesitate to get married mary's
pregnancy is spirit conceived
god's holy spirit has made her pregnant
she will bring a son to birth and when
she does
you joseph will name him jesus
god saves because he will save his
people from their sins
this would bring the prophet's embryonic
sermon to full term
watch for this a virgin will get
pregnant and bear a son
they will name him emmanuel hebrew for
god
is with us then joseph woke up
he did exactly what god's angel
commanded in the dream
he married mary but he did not
consummate the marriage until she had
the baby
he named the baby jesus matthew 2
13-15 when they had gone an angel of the
lord appeared to joseph in a dream
get up he said take the child and his
mother and escape to egypt
stay there until i tell you for herod is
going to search for the child to kill
him
so he got up took the child and his
mother during the night and left for
egypt
where he stayed until the death of herod
and so was fulfilled what the lord had
said to the prophet
out of egypt i called my son
well good evening everyone grace and
peace
and a huge thank you to nikki uh parker
for that
wonderful reading and uh to
mindy and maggie and melody for the time
of music and of course for karen for
kicking us off so
um yeah i'm just i'm really really
grateful to
be with all of you live tonight
and um it's you know as much as i would
just
love to be in person um it's
it's you know really such a um a gift
to have this medium you know to connect
so
uh i'm grateful and my heart is full uh
just to be with all of you tonight
so we are in this is part four
and our series titled stretch then uh
what to do when life pushes you to the
limit
and um i've talked about you know this
series a number of times i think it's in
many ways
you know self-explanatory so won't go
and do it too much but
this is it's just a season where we're
being called to a lot
um you know and life itself can just be
challenging enough
um and you start adding other
layers on top of it as we're all facing
and it's
just just a bit much and so um
that's kind of in the series what we're
really doing is just looking again to
the scriptures
uh to jesus um for wisdom for insight
for um really a
fresh way of seeing god in the midst
of our stretching and um
and and for ways to kind of grow into it
so
that's very much the spirit of the
message tonight um which is titled
simply messy messy and
this is kind of just my big idea
messy doesn't mean your life is broken
messy means it's working
that's the big idea messy doesn't mean
your life is broken
messy means it's working i
have a mentor and um
and he's been in my life for a number of
years um and really specifically at my
last church he was like very very
connected uh to me and i had a number of
them but but this one in particular
um he's just a wonderful man his name uh
is doug fike
and doug he's sort of like i don't know
what you call him kind of a bishop
of sorts like he wasn't himself a pastor
of a local church instead he was sort of
a pastor of pastors
you know every pastor needs to be
pastored and so uh
doug would come into town about maybe
two or three times a year
and he would uh meet with various um the
staff
and um leadership teams of the church
and
you know he had a lot of wisdom to share
uh
just a wonderful perspective on on many
different things
but i noticed that really his primary
task
seemed to be something along these lines
so he would
um meet with with you and he would kind
of sit down
and you know he was very kind and he was
a good question asker very good so he'd
sort of
draw you out with the questions and you
would start
to share you know about your life and i
mean all the things he wasn't just you
didn't just care about
ministry he would talk about you know
your life your your marriage your kids
your
um and of course also maybe your
leadership team or your church or
organization or whatever
and uh and so you know you start to
share and of course there are always
you know the highlights some positive
things
uh but inevitably you know life being
what it is
you i would also begin to to talk about
the
challenges you know i mean i don't care
who the person is who the family is
who the organization or the business or
the church is if you get beneath the
surface with someone
the truth is that we are all
more than a bit of a hot mess right
things
are things are not always going smoothly
not even always
things are almost never going smoothly i
think of it like we're all sort of like
ducks
maintaining that look of calm of
serenity on the surface
paddling furiously underneath the water
that's you know to kind of stay up like
everything's fine uh that's you know
that's sort of our life and so i noticed
in
in my meetings with doug that they
followed this structure
you know that he would ask the questions
it was a safe place to share
about my hot mess of a life and emotions
and feelings and griefs and challenges
and you know we got to share what wasn't
go going according to plan
uh we got to open up about what was not
going so well i say we cause it was
often
me and maggie my wife that would meet
with him and
uh and then eventually my leadership
team so we'd all be there you know
opening up sharing and
he would listen uh and you know ask the
occasional clarifying question
uh and then it would be his turn to
speak
and inevitably after we had shared for
the last hour about what a catastrophe
everything was
he would say thank you thank you for
sharing
this this is what it looks like
when it is working
that's what he would say this is what it
looks like
when it is working when it is
working what on earth did he mean
i i think this was actually a really
wise perspective because you see he
understood
that god's goal for my life
is not that i learn to project a sense
of flawlessness
and it's not that i become outwardly
successful in terms of you know what
what are the things the culture values
the culture around us money wealth power
status
um those things you know may or may not
happen but but they're just they're not
the goal
god's goal for my life it is it's not
static
you see we want to arrive don't we
we want to get the high score land the
perfect
10 and then freeze
freeze everything we want to arrive
god wants us to become
[Music]
we want to arrive god wants us to become
you and i are on a journey of
endless becoming an
endless journey of growing deeper
and deeper higher and higher unending
becoming
and you might ask um becoming
becoming what well it's it's not a what
uh i think it's more like a who
becoming like god
god's will is that through every
challenge every setback every
failure that we would grow
that we would mature that as ephesians 4
13 says that we would attain to the
whole measure of the fullness
of christ that's a big statement
what does that mean it means that
through the holy spirit and by the grace
of god
that whatever is false in in me
in us that whatever is fake and selfish
would would just be burned away by the
fire of his love until what remains
in us is nothing but the compassion the
purity and the presence of the living
god we've come to know in jesus and and
here's the key
that process tends not to happen
to us so much when we're on vacation
unfortunately that's how we would all
love it
if only we could go on perpetual
vacation and just
grow and grow and grow but when does it
happen it
happens when we are stretched
thin when we reach the edge of what we
can
handle we reach the end of ourselves
and we find there a strength a love
holding us sustaining us
and we learn to trust
we learn to be people who operate um
by by faith and not by sight as the
scriptures say i love that statement we
operate by faith
not by sight in other words not by what
we see
not by our circumstances right we we
become a
god directed people
not in external circumstances directed
people
and so twice a year doug would come into
town
and we would go through this process
where he would name
that this is key that as long as we were
saying yes
to god as long as we continue to lean
into the growing
up the maturing work of god in our lives
um because that's essential right it's
not enough for things simply to be messy
i'm not saying tonight that you know
messy and chaotic merely for the sake of
messy and chaotic is god's goal he's
just like two thumbs up
of course not right the idea is that the
mess and the chaos does what
it pushes us pushes us towards god
it teaches us to lean in and say
yes to wherever god is inviting us to go
and to grow and so doug's message was
that as long as we kept doing that
no matter how messy it looked it was
working
it was working it was working that's
god's message to you tonight
it's it's working as long as you keep
leaning in
it's working and you might wonder
um why on earth did you need someone to
come twice a year to tell you the same
thing
over and over and i'll tell you why
because over and over again
i would forget i would forget
that this is what it looks like
when it is working you see messy doesn't
mean your life
is broken messy
means it's working
and you know what strikes me about the
story of the birth of jesus from matthew
chapters
one and two that nikki just read a
little while ago
um is really just how contentious
and dangerous and messy
everything is did you notice this
perhaps you know
you're like familiar with the story so
it just sort of
rolled right over you without it sinking
in but like pay attention to the story
um i mean if if i were writing this
story
jesus would almost certainly have been
born in
a palace to wealthy parents you know to
ensure he had all the advantages of a
good education
uh and frankly we all know how important
the early years
are to a child's development right like
it's a time for a sense of peace
and serenity so the child can feel loved
and safe and grow up to be an
emotionally stable human being
so if i were writing the story jesus
would not have been born out in the
styx nazareth whoever heard of nazareth
to
to peasant parents he would have been
born in the big city
to the royal family and if frankly if i
were writing the story
the angel wouldn't have appeared
only to mary but to the whole town
right to let them all know bring them
into the loop hey people
look mary's pregnancy is a god thing so
don't you go getting all judgy with her
in making her life miserable i know your
type so
insecure you feel the need to gossip
about it to others so you feel better
about yourselves in your own life
like that's see that's what he should
have that's what he should have done
i also think the the angel should have
appeared to joseph's parents
as a former young man myself um you know
i can imagine that would have been
helpful like just to let them know hey
please don't give joseph any crap about
this
all right support him he's going to need
it
uh i mean how do you how do you think
they thought when their little boy
joseph decided to proceed with the
marriage
because he had some mystical encounter
with an angel
right like and and then here's what's
fascinating in chapter two
because i hadn't could do these two
readings so if you notice in chapter two
then jesus is a toddler uh and
rather than getting better
what happens things get worse
like now they're fleeing for their lives
to a foreign country now they're
immigrants
trying to rebuild their shattered lives
like do you think they prayed
god this is not
what i signed up for
you ever prayed that prayer
that's it that's a rubber meets the road
that's a real prayer
an honest prayer a dangerous prayer god
this is not
what i thought i signed up for and you
know it's it's fascinating
um scholars speculate that the reason we
don't hear much about joseph after this
like mary you'll notice if you've read
the gospels um the stories the full
story
you'll know she kind of continues to be
mentioned from time to time uh
but never joseph and they they speculate
scholars speculate it's it's probably
because
joseph at some point in jesus growing up
years
uh died
died young like what
what was was this was this the plan
and and yet it's so it's so fascinating
to me that when we
put out a manger scene you know the
nativity scene on our front lawn
or on our mantle in the living room
uh everything is so serene
isn't it like the looks on all their
faces
just so idyllic and
angelic and i'm i'm not of course saying
that major scenes are bad or something
it's good to be reminded of the story
and by the way i do think that the text
indicates that mary perhaps even joseph
had a certain piece of heart in mind
in the midst of this right it's possible
for life to be messy and for you and i
to be at peace
right in the midst of it that that's
part of the learning process
uh but when we set our little serene
nativity scenes out i think there is a
danger
and the danger is that we drown the
story
in nostalgia in a
wished for sort of culturally
sanitized version of the past
that we reimagine the story as the
picture
of christmas flawlessness
and perfection when to the people
actually living it what was it
messy it was
messy as in broken relationships
messy other people's judgments
messy fearing for your life
messy moving to a foreign country
messy people you love dying
messy and as i reflect
on this year what what has this year
been for us
messi social isolation
messy political polarization
messy racism messy
kids trying to do school from home while
parents try to work
messy teachers god bless our teachers
we have a number of teachers at the
table you all are saints and you know
frankly teachers that are already
underpaid
and like stressed out and this year has
been almost
more than many of you could cope with
messy what what has this year been
it's job loss messy dwindling
savings messy family conflict over
masks and pandemics vs plan
demix and presidents
messi and i mean we'll just keep going
depression
messy and all my means shot to
heck messy that's the churchy version
shot to heck
messy and church through a screen well
frankly everything through a screen
messy and children acting out messy or
for the older kids
parents freaking out messy
but does that mean that it's been a
wasted year
does that mean god has forsaken us does
it mean
that we just didn't do it quite right
you know there's a a beautiful story in
the old testament
uh i'll close with this it's it's of a
man named joseph not
joseph um dad to jesus but different
joseph
and his life oh my uh talk about messi
it was basically just one catastrophe
after another
i won't go into all the details but
suffice it to say it involved
um getting thrown into a pit by his own
brothers and then they sold him into
slavery
and then he eventually worked his way up
to house slave
but then he got falsely accused of a
crime so then he gets thrown into
prison and he stays there for years
someone promises they'll get him out
they don't uh but eventually through a
series of bizarre dreams and god moments
he
rises to become second in command of the
entire egyptian empire
and there's this whole dramatic moment
where his brothers they have to stand
before him
now trembling because i mean
now joseph has all the power and now
it's his turn
to enact vengeance and joseph says this
remarkable thing
he looks at his brothers the very ones
who had kicked off this whole series of
catastrophes
by selling him as a slave and he looks
at them and he says
you meant evil against me but
god used it for good
you meant evil against me but god used
it for
good i love that line god used it for
good see this is why messi is good
not because messi is inherently good
messi
is just chaotic and well messy but
but god takes our mess and he says oh i
can work
with this i can work with this
you see it's not that god causes the
mess
it's not that he brings catastrophe into
your life to teach you a lesson
it's that he takes the chaos
of our lives and the disasters of our
own foolishness
and he uses it all
he uses it i promise you to deepen
us to mature us to help us
become people of great faith hope and
love
people like jesus
see messi doesn't mean your life is
broken
messy means it's working
i pray for you lord jesus
i lift up this little community
and every person listening to my voice
their lives are messy right now
and i pray that you would meet them in
the midst of it
that they would sense your nearness and
your presence god especially for those
who
they just feel abandoned they just feel
so chaotic
and the story that they've told is that
that you've abandoned them
that you are not near that that you are
not
love that no good can come from this
but god you are writing a new
story though others intended it for evil
you intend it for the good
and you're weaving
a new life for them one
of peace and wholeness and strength and
resilience and
courage and faith
god so do your deep work in us
do it in me do it in all of us god
we love you the powerful name of jesus i
pray
amen
hey everybody thanks for being here
tonight um
we're one sunday closer to getting to be
together
and i can't wait for that um this week
was uh was tough for me
i feel like every week we could say it's
getting crazy
because it is um but this week hit me
differently
i didn't realize it until
friday afternoon and uh
i hope it's okay to share this before i
sing the song because
the song uh changed me this week that
i'm gonna sing
i sit on the couch and joe asked me
she's like hey have you heard of brandon
bernard
and uh i was like no who's that
and the minute i said no who is that i
realized
i knew exactly who that was because i
had been reading about it
all week and then thursday night he was
executed
and i realized friday night or friday
afternoon
that that weighed heavily on me
and then i realized i had to sing this
song called beautiful things
for sunday and
i guess my brain and my heart knew that
there was going to be a battle
because i had forgotten
brandon bernard's name um after
days of studying his story um
up until thursday night when they when
he was executed um
and it it got me it
it hurts to think about um that
we are the beautiful things of god that
we are love
we are made in his image and he is love
and that we have the ability to do these
things
and justify them in our own brains
and i'm singing this song practicing and
you know there's questions that are are
in this song
and the verses they say you know thing i
wonder if i'll ever find my way
i wonder if my life could really change
um could could all that is lost ever be
found
and i'm saying this i'm like no the
answer all that is
no um and then comes the chorus where
it's like you make beautiful things
you make beautiful things out of dust
and you make beautiful things out of us
and uh i'm like not buying it
you know i'm singing this song and i'm
not buying it
but then i come to the bridge and
when we get to the bridge when we sing
it i want to sing it all together
if you're at home online um
i know we can't hear each other but but
let's sing it together because it's
powerful
it's the hope that we all need and the
bridge says you make me new
you're making me new
it's a continual growing process into
being new
and um
it's we never arrive and that gives me
hope because i look around and i'm
thinking
we are so far from getting there
and i realize we're not going to get
there but we're going to continually be
made new
continually being made new he is making
us new
uh being made new today isn't enough
because tomorrow it's going to be old
and we're going to be made new again so
let this be
uh our prayer
and our challenge and charge
to be the kingdom
to help people being made new
um every day
so uh i've got the ambient light around
it's going to be kind of a raw set i
usually put on a collared shirt
but i still feel like being extra
tonight
um i just felt like
i struggled with this song and uh
i just wanted to be me so you know there
may be
a wrong chord a wrong note but this is a
prayer
of my heart and it's hard to get through
because i don't buy all of it
but i buy the bridge where i'm being
made new
and i'm gonna continually try um
to live up to that uh so
uh sit back and and sing with me please
for
[Music]
i this if i'll ever
find my way
i wonder if my life could
really change
[Music]
all this earth
good all that is
[Music]
you make beautiful things
oh
[Music]
is
you make beautiful things
[Music]
out of
yes
you make beautiful things
[Music]
this is
me
you make me
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
you make me
yes
[Music]
is
me
[Music]
you make me
continually be made new every day
thanks josh that was beautiful and
thanks to all of you
for being with us tonight i hope
that the time together
spoke to you in some way and reminded
you that you are not alone
i also wanted to give a shout out to
everyone who contributed to the service
tonight and
to scott and marissa for doing the
behind the scenes work
to make the technology
and the moderating of the comments go
smoothly so thanks guys
um also if you are in need
of prayer a listening ear or anything
please don't hesitate to reach out to us
i believe that marissa's going to put a
link up you can
shoot us an email and we would love to
talk with you uh
also if you resonate with the values
and the vision and the community that
we've got going on here at the table
please consider a financial gift just to
ensure
that our work continues to flourish
and move forward and you can do that
through our website
at thetabletx.org
so as you go into your week let me send
you off with this
benediction you
are a child of god this is true
on your best days and on your worst days
you are wonderfully and lovingly made
there is only one you nothing
about you is a mistake and this world
needs you being fully yourself authentic
and free so as you go into the week
ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted just
as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
gifts
of grace and unconditional love to
everyone
you come in contact with i hope you have
a great week
and i hope to see you back here next
sunday bye
you